who's certain they've actually had a
dream about
me okay let's explore this this might
get us somewh interesting does anyone
want to share the content of their dream
yes you well
um I'm in this Forest wandering around
eating these strange
mushrooms and I'm in like a full tuxedo
for some
reason and there's other people also
dressed up but they're all scared like
Frozen in fear and then I realized it's
because of this really tall man running
towards
me
hi are you talking to me yes Paul he'll
kill us Paul I've never seen
these
beautiful and that's all I
remember H interesting so I'm looking at
the mushrooms instead of helping oh I
suppose yeah okay let's hear another one
anyone
okay so I'm just observing again but
that's funny interesting one anyone
else